as the great kenny rogers once said you
got to know when to hold them and know
when to fold them
your team's down 30 with five minutes
left might be time to sneak out and beat
the traffic home
at a house party past 2 a.m that's why
ray is finished hit the door
sorry we're so late actually the party
is over what
the party is over
a musician needs to know when the
audience has had enough
i give
[Music]
sorry
over the last couple weeks the democrats
realized the pandemic's over now i'm not
saying covet is no longer a risk it
certainly is but not to most of us the
most vulnerable to covet or the old and
the overweight the people who run the
country happen to be just that
i didn't mean to offend anybody but
medically speaking my 10 month old can
crawl faster than members of congress
can run
so they all got scared of getting sick
they made up a bunch of asinine rules to
protect themselves and punish everyone
else we were lied to about lockdowns
masks school closings and coveted
treatments but this isn't the first time
we were sold a big fat lie
when soda was first introduced it was
considered a miracle cure and it was
actually sold at pharmacy counters all
across the country
then later
sugary sodas kill people and make us all
diabetic
this is what society does
fifteen years ago they were recommending
trans fats
now they're illegal
just like almost 100 prescription drugs
which were once called safe and
effective and then yanked off the market
because they were not we've had this
problem in medicine for a long time the
same people who in private care
always say get a second opinion
want to allow only one
in the public debate
the left's waking up we kind of shook
them awake
but some of them won't admit they ever
fell asleep
and there is no bigger hypocrite than
mascoid's stacey abrams who writes
erotic novels and gets all-star games
cancelled in her free time
here she sits around maskless grinning
ear to ear while literally everybody
else in the room was massed up
read the room stacy
she is completely oblivious to the
suffering around her
she had to delete that picture and then
also deleted other pictures of herself
like this one here where she's sitting
and just smiling while the allies
prepare to invade normandy not a care in
the world
but rather than be an adult her campaign
saying this
it is shameful that our opponents are
using a black history month reading
event for georgia children as the
impetus for a false political attack
so she's going with the black history
month defense
i thought for sure should use the la
meyer defense and claim she wasn't
breathing but hey at least she didn't
compare us to cavemen
masks make a difference the last thing
we need is neanderthal thinking that in
the meantime everything's fine take off
your mask forget it it still matters
do people still trust biden when it
comes to covet well we wanted to know so
we sent some of our producers out into
the streets to find out
are you still afraid of the coronavirus
no i'm not it's what it is i wouldn't
use the word afraid no i really wasn't
ever afraid of the chronovirus of course
yeah i am a melanated black man that has
the melanation in my skin from the sun
rays that protect me from all type of
things he thinks the sun god will
protect him are you vaccinated i am
vaccinated with a booster yes plus
booster too no vaccine
no policy of the president i don't
follow another day laws are you
vaccinated yeah i have all three shots
then why are you wearing your mask
outside
um i don't we just come in and out of
places so i just keep it on it's cold
outside it keeps your face warm i'm
wearing it right now because you're
pretty close to me i don't know too
close too close too close how do you
feel about the studies research that
suggests that cloth masks don't work as
long as you're covering your face with
something at least you're helping hello
it was kind of funny in an italian
restaurant the other day everybody's
right on top of each other no one's got
masks on but as soon as you get a front
table you gotta put one on so it's a
little silly there's like a mask my
pocket mask in my bag what do you think
of vaccine mandates i think vaccine
mandates are a little unconstitutional i
think unvaccinated people are kind of
scary
[Music]
how do you feel about vaccine mandates
i think it's it's very important i would
not be going into restaurants anywhere
if i didn't know that people had to have
their car checked when they walked in
i'm not a doctor
so i do not know well if you can still
transmit the virus being vaccinated do
you think it makes any difference then
no it doesn't that's a good point that's
a good point she has a good point do you
trust dr fauci
i do i don't know if he's in somebody's
pocket or what his true intentions are
we gotta trust him right because he's
the leader over here why considering he
was wrong on mass the loudly lockdowns
why because
who else are we gonna listen to who else
is there
he's clearly lying about you know data
function research do you trust dr fauci
dr fauci who is that come on seriously
who is that joe biden he promised to
shut down the virus how do you think
that's going
you can't promise anything i don't think
any one single person has that power i'm
liberal but i don't
i don't necessarily approve of biden i
don't remember him saying that so i'll
just go by your word i've said it before
i'm not gonna shut down the economy
i'm not gonna shut down the country i'm
gonna shut down the virus i think it is
time and that we cannot shut down the
country forever joe biden is not for the
people i don't have any faith in this
government
we've lost faith in the feds so now it's
up to the governors again blue states
like california gave in to lockdowns and
the mandates and texas allowed its
people to stay free and the state boomed
look at that
here's the good news all across the
country we're seeing progress on the
fight against these mandates and we're
winning blue states like new jersey
pennsylvania delaware they're all
dropping their school mask mandates our
kids can breathe again
and remember when you were a child
food on your face you know your mom
comes over and wipes it off and you
squirm like crazy
mom tried to make you wear a sweater but
you were too hot it just squished up
against your collar and you'd throw a
fit
or girls your mother went to go brush
your hair and it was all naughty
how much that hurt you'd cry
you wanted to have control over your own
head
you didn't want grown-ups fussing all
over your face that was your face
think about how much suffering these
young kids are experiencing with these
itchy suffocating masks on
breathing all day like a scuba diver
if you're wearing glasses all fogged up
you can't tell if your classmates are
smiling at you or scowling
how do you even know if your jokes are
landing
watching grown-ups prance around with no
masks children are very keen on fairness
but mom dad it's not fair they always
tell us that
nothing is more unfair
than the people least likely to be hurt
by covet having to wear masks while the
overweight older people go maskless
why is it fair you can go massless at a
restaurant but not at a school
so history has a way of sorting out
what's right and wrong you see
the pandemic party is over for the
democrats some of them have just haven't
realized it yet
too many people can't move on from their
sense of moral superiority that the
pandemic gave them
they'll forever cling to the power they
had to point fingers at faces and ban
you from buildings
they found their spot in the coved
social hierarchy and they don't want to
surrender but they don't have a choice
anymore by speaking your mind and
fighting for what's right
you made the choice for them
thank you america hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else